Vous le savez, nous devons impérativement
limiter notre impact sur l'environnement.
C'est pour cette raison que je vous parle
régulièrement
de transition énergétique
et d'énergies renouvelables.
Si d'ailleurs vous souhaitez
que je continue
à aborder ce type de sujets.
Faites-le moi
savoir en likant cette vidéo.
Je disais donc,
limiter notre impact sur l'environnement
et notamment
nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre.
Aujourd'hui, on s'attaque
à un gros morceau : le gaz.
Il existe une façon vertueuse
de le produire
en transformant de la matière organique
issue des exploitations agricoles.
Un processus plus connu
sous le nom de méthanisation.
Comment fait-on ?
Je vous explique tout ça,
dans l'atelier, ça urge.
Le gaz. Plus précisément,
le méthane, CH4, est
une source d'énergie que nous utilisons
dans de nombreuses situations
pour nous chauffer, cuisiner
et même pour nous déplacer.
C'est aussi une source d'énergie
qui se stocke facilement.
Le méthane est donc aussi utilisé
pour ajuster la production électrique,
notamment
lors des grands pics de consommation,
comme en hiver.
Le revers de la médaille, c'est que
ce que nous appelons pudiquement gaz
naturel est une énergie fossile,
avec tout ce que cela entraîne.
C'est un hydrocarbure.
Au même titre que le pétrole, qu'il
faut extraire du sous-sol
transporter jusqu'au
lieu de consommation et brûler
afin qu'il libère son énergie.
Mais au passage, il libère aussi du CO2,
un gaz à effet de serre
responsable des dérèglements climatiques.
Précisons également
que la ressource n'est pas infinie.
Elle est limitée,
non-renouvelable à l'échelle humaine.
Enfin, il ne vous aura pas échappé
que l'accès à cette ressource
est soumis
aux aléas géopolitiques,
parfois plus que tendus.
La Russie, par exemple, possède
près d'un quart
des ressources mondiales.
Difficile malgré tout
de se passer de gaz dans l'absolu.
On l'a vu pour se chauffer, pour cuisiner,
pour produire de l'électricité.
Nous en avons encore besoin.
Mais dans le même temps,
il est urgent de réduire nos émissions
de gaz à effet de serre et d'être
moins dépendant de certains pays.
La bonne nouvelle,
c'est qu'il existe des pistes
pour faire pencher la balance du bon côté.
Il s'agit de produire ce que l'on appelle
du biogaz.
Allez, pour y voir plus clair.
On part sur le terrain,
on va à la ferme.
Comme vous pouvez
le constater ici, rien à voir
avec un site d'extraction de gaz.
Il n'y a pas de derrick
ni de forage profond.
Et pour cause, on ne va pas chercher
le gaz dans le sol, mais plutôt
sur le sol.
C'est tout l'intérêt de la méthanisation.
Utiliser des déchets
que l'on qualifie d'organique,
issus du vivant en quelque sorte,
pour produire du gaz.
C'est une des raisons
pour lesquelles la méthanisation se marie
si bien avec l'agriculture.
Il suffit de se baisser
pour récupérer de la matière première.
On peut utiliser des effluents
d'élevage,
autrement dit des bouses de vache,
des déchets de culture,
la partie des végétaux
que nous ne consommons pas,
ou encore des cultures intermédiaires.
C'est à dire des végétaux
que l'on fait pousser
entre deux récoltes pour protéger les sols
et maintenir leur qualité.
Qu'on les récupère ou
qu'on les laisse sur le terrain,
tous ces déchets organiques
finissent par se dégrader,
par pourrir et larguer dans l'atmosphère,
le carbone qu'ils ont accumulé
dans leurs tissus au cours de leur vie.
L'idée, c'est donc de capter ce carbone
sous forme de méthane.
Mais pour ça, il faut donner
un petit coup de pouce à la nature,
je vous explique dans l'atelier.
Cette fameuse matière organique
récupérée dans les champs
est composée essentiellement de carbone,
d'hydrogène et d'oxygène.
C H O
Elle est introduite, en permanence,
dans une cuve fermée
qu'on appelle un digesteur
où elle est maintenue
à 40 degrés
et brassée en continue.
Un dernier point avant de jeter un œil
à ce bouillon de culture.
La transformation s'effectue en l'absence
d'air.
C'est un fonctionnement dit
"anaérobie"
qui va favoriser le développement
et le travail
de différents types de bactéries.
Elles se développent naturellement
et vont se succéder
pour découper
la matière organique, la digérer,
la transformer
et recombiner ses composants.
Jusqu'à obtenir,
au bout de quelques dizaines de jours,
du biogaz, c'est à dire
essentiellement du méthane
et du dioxyde de carbone.
Vous noterez que l'on retrouve
le carbone, l'hydrogène
et l'oxygène présents
au départ dans la matière organique,
mais recombinés.
Rien ne se perd, tout se transforme, comme on dit.
Alors évidemment, même si le processus
est tout à fait naturel,
il faut malgré tout une installation
pour maîtriser ce processus, l'optimiser
et le mener
à bien en toute sécurité.
Mais il faut aussi un certain
savoir-faire, on retourne tout de suite
sur le terrain et nous allons
rencontrer
le maître des lieux,
Jean-François.
- Merci Jean-François de nous accueillir
sur votre exploitation.
Alors , j'ai bien compté,
il y a quatre digesteurs ici,
quatre cuves.
- Exactement. Mais en fait,
il y a trois cuves principales
qui digèrent. Des digesteurs,
comme tu as dit.
Et la quatrième,
elle vient finir le travail
et préparer l'étape suivante.
Au total, c'est 22 000 mètres cubes
qui sont digérés ici.
- Et quel type de déchets ?
- Uniquement des déchets organiques végétaux
issus des industries agroalimentaires
ou des biodéchets.
- On peut faire le tour ?
- Bien sûr !
- Alors ça, qu'est-ce que c'est ?
- Alors ça,
ce sont des plantes qui sont ensilées,
ça veut dire des plantes vertes issues
des champs agricoles,
qui sont coupées, broyées, stockées ici.
- D'accord, ici, on ne dame pas les pistes,
on dame l'ensilage.
- On dame l'ensilage pour le conserver,
être à la fois délicat
et fort et le conserver
le plus longtemps possible.
- D'accord, mais ça, ce n'est pas des déchets, ça vient d'où ?
- Ça vient des exploitations agricoles,
de la mienne et de celle des voisins.
- On passe à côté ?
- Ouais.
- Alors là, on passe du vert au brun.
- Là, on passe à des déchets qui sont issus
de l'industrie agro-alimentaire,
donc qui ont subi
une première transformation.
Tu as les poussières de céréales, là à droite.
- Juste là, devant moi, là ?
- Ouais, poussières de céréales. Alors, on nettoie les céréales
dans des coopératives locales.
Au fond, c'est la pulpe de betterave.
Ça, ça veut dire que mes betteraves
sont transformées, on récupère le sucre
et moi,
je vais chercher ce qui reste, les racines,
pour les remettre
dans mes champs.
L'énergie m'intéresse,
mais c'est surtout retrouver un équilibre
avec mon sol.
- Et là, juste à côté ?
- Et là, c'est d'autres déchets issus de l'industrie agroalimentaire,
en l'occurrence issus des industries de colza.
Ce qu'on appel le diester, les biocarburants,
les matières pour les éleveurs.
- Alors ça, ce sont des matières solides. Mais les bactéries,
elles, n'ont pas besoin de liquide ?
- Alors effectivement, ça,
c'est l'ensemble des matières solides.
C'est la base de l'alimentation des bactéries.
Mais c'est difficile à digérer
en tant que tel pour les bactéries.
Donc on ajoute du liquide et dorénavant
le liquide est stocké derrière nous.
Ce sont des biodéchets issus de l'industrie
agroalimentaire, des restaurants
et aussi du lactosérum,
les fromageries locales,
les résidus qui ont un peu d'énergie
et qui nous servent à diluer
et permettre
aux bactéries de mieux travailler.
- Alors ici,
c'est vous qui faites la cuisine.
C'est quoi la recette ?
Le bon dosage ?
- Le bon dosage ici, c'est environ un tiers,
un tiers, un tiers.
C'est à dire un tiers issu de mon exploitation
agricole et des voisins,
un tiers issus
des industries agroalimentaires locales
et puis un tiers issu
de la grande région parisienne,
les déchets, les biodéchets.
- Tout ça
donc pour faire du méthane.
Alors avant de découvrir le produit final,
et bien on va faire un petit point
sur le process de production.
Je retourne dans l'atelier
et on se retrouve tout de suite.
- Ça me va, je t'attends là bas.
- Parfait.
Sympa, Jean-François.
Les bactéries dans le digesteur
transforment
donc la matière première en biogaz.
En grande partie du CO2 et du CH4.
Après un petit nettoyage,
ce gaz peut être directement
utilisé sur l'exploitation.
Pour faire tourner une turbine
et produire de l'électricité
ainsi que de la chaleur.
Jean-François,
lui, a opté pour l'injection de ce gaz
dans le réseau.
C'est à dire qu'il va vendre sa production
et l'envoyer
dans le réseau classique de gaz.
Un choix qui permet d'alimenter
de nombreux foyers,
mais qui demande
quelques opérations supplémentaires.
Il va falloir débarrasser
le biogaz de son CO2
pour en faire du biométhane
utilisable par les équipements domestiques.
Pour y parvenir,
la technique la plus utilisée
s'appelle la séparation membranaire.
J'explique. Une molécule de CO2
est plus petite,
qu'une molécule de méthane (CH4).
Pour les séparer et surtout
ne garder que le méthane.
Il suffit de placer une membrane
qui va agir
comme un filtre ou comme un tamis,
si vous préférez.
Ces mailles seront suffisamment grandes
pour laisser s'échapper le CO2,
mais suffisamment
petites pour retenir le méthane.
Et non, ça ne passe pas.
Même en serrant les coudes.
Dernière chose
le méthane étant inodore à l'état brut,
il reste à ajouter,
pour des raisons de sécurité,
l'odeur typique
du gaz,
cette odeur de soufre qui nous permet
d'identifier rapidement une fuite.
Alors évidemment,
une fois acheminé jusque chez nous,
ce biométhane est tout
de même brûlé par notre cuisinière
ou notre ballon d'eau chaude.
Et il dégage du CO2.
Alors, me direz-vous,
quel est l'intérêt d'une telle énergie ?
Et bien, la grande différence,
c'est qu'il ne s'agit pas d'une
énergie fossile.
Le gaz naturel est un hydrocarbure,
c'est à dire qu'il est extrait du sous-sol
où il était piégé
depuis des millions d'années.
Lorsqu'il est brûlé, il libère
donc du carbone du CO2
supplémentaire dans l'atmosphère.
À l'inverse, le biométhane
ou le biogaz en général
s'inscrit dans un cycle court.
Observons ce qu'il se passe sur une année.
Le carbone de l'atmosphère est capté
sous forme de CO2
par une plante en pleine croissance.
Elle l'utilise pour pousser.
Lorsque vient la récolte,
le carbone stocké dans sa tige
et dans ses feuilles est récupéré
pour former du biogaz.
Ce dernier, au moment
où il est brûlé, relargue
alors le CO2
précédemment capté par la plante.
Finalement, il n'y a pas d'introduction
supplémentaire de CO2 dans l'atmosphère.
On fonctionne en circuit fermé.
Et ça, ça change tout.
Mais ce n'est pas le seul avantage
de la production de biogaz.
Vous allez le voir,
les agriculteurs trouvent
un autre intérêt à la méthanisation.
On retourne voir Jean-François,
il nous attend.
- Voilà.
Alors ça, c'est ce qu'il
reste après le travail des bactéries,
c'est ce qu'on appelle le digestat,
et contrairement à ce que l'on pourrait
penser, ce n'est pas un déchet.
- Exactement.
C'est une matière noble à mes yeux,
parce qu'elle va servir à nourrir le sol d'abord,
nourrir les plantes
derrière, c'est une matière riche
qui contient
l'ensemble des éléments fertilisants.
Azote, potasse; classique.
Qui sont les éléments fertilisants
classiques de l'agriculture.
Mais aussi des microéléments,
des vitamines,
de la matière organique, des fibres.
Tout un tas de choses très variées
pour nourrir les plantes.
- Et il en reste beaucoup puisque, à partir
des 22 000 tonnes de matière organique
que vous traitez pour la méthanisation,
et bien il reste
19 000 tonnes de ce digestat.
Vous le stockez où ?
- On le stocke dans des lagunes,
c'est à dire des bassins
à proximité des champs,
en deux endroits différents
pour l'utiliser dans les champs
aux périodes les plus propices de l'année.
- Ça veut donc dire aujourd'hui
que vous êtes
agriculteur, producteur de méthane
et aussi producteur d'intrant ?
- Oui, et c'est ma motivation initiale.
Ce que j'ai le plus à cœur
dans ce projet là,
ça reste le digestat.
C'est à dire, trouver
un engrais de substitution organique,
être indépendant, autonome.
- Ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui,
vous n'utilisez plus d'engrais
de synthèse ?
- Plus aucun.
- Merci beaucoup Jean-François de nous avoir fait découvrir
votre exploitation.
Cette activité.
Et puis comment,
à partir de ces
produits végétaux,
de ces déchets organiques, et bien,
on peut produire à la fois des engrais
et du méthane.
Merci Jamy !
Et bien, voilà une piste de plus
pour réduire nos émissions de gaz
à effet de serre, gagner en indépendance
et en autonomie énergétique.
Alors, pour le moment,
la production française de biométhane
ne représente que 3%
de la consommation nationale de gaz.
Il faut à la fois
permettre à cette pratique de se répandre
un peu plus sans tomber
dans des excès,
comme une activité agricole
entièrement dédiée à la production de gaz,
ce qui n'aurait aucun sens.
Et puis, produire du gaz plus propre,
ça ne veut pas dire en consommer
davantage.
Comme toujours lorsqu'on
parle de transition énergétique,
l'énergie la plus propre,
évidemment, c'est celle qu'on
ne consomme pas.